[موسيقى]
وطلب الخدمه
ارحم
من يقوم بهذه الخدمه
وفي هذه الحريه الحقيقه الساطعه امنح
النعمه لكل البشريه في كل الديانات
والمعتقدات هذا معا يمكن ان يسمح لنا
باكتشاف
السبيل السلام من خلال المسيح
امين
[موسيقى]
اذا قام الملك تشارلز الثالث
باداء القسم
وبتلاوه قسم التتويج وكما ذكرنا هو شرط
قانوني لاكتمال هذه المراسم
بعد قليل ستبدا المرحله الثالثه من مراسم
التتويج وهي تتعلق
بالمسح بالزيت المقدس وهذه
مرحله لديها خصوصيه كبيره
وستتم بسريه وبعيدا عن اعين الحضور وعدسات
الكاميرات
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات